Speaker 1: We've used the term stochastic
terrorism before on the show.
Stochastic terrorism is sort of the idea that
while not being a physical, in-person terrorist
yourself, if you have a big enough audience
and you float an idea to them of doing something
with a big enough audience, it becomes statistically
more and more likely that someone in the audience
is going to listen to what you're saying,
and they're going to go out there and they're
going to commit an act of terror.
We've looked at a number of these examples
in the past.
One is a guy who we used to listen to Glenn
Beck rant and rave about an organization called
the Tides Foundation and was actually intercepted
by California Highway Patrol, armed and heading
to do something at the Tides Foundation.
Comet ping pong is another example when Republicans
were going crazy about the Pizzagate conspiracy
theory and this pizza shop in Washington,
D.C., and saying they're harboring pedophiles,
they're helping part of, you know, whatever
it was they were saying, pedophiles are meeting
here and trafficking young kids or whatever.
A guy actually went and shot up comet ping
pong.
So there's a real effect here.
Republicans, a Republican audience listening
to the chairman of the Oklahoma Republican
Party, John Bennett, who's also running for
the House of Representatives.
They cheered when John Bennett said, we should
kill Fauci.
We should put Fauci in front of a firing squad.
Now, I'm certain that John Bennett is pro-life,
and I'm certain that John Bennett is a Christian
because there's a jersey up on the screen
behind him that says if aphasia is Ephesians,
I don't even know how to pronounce it and
there is a cross.
And so this is a pro-life Christian guy, in
case you weren't sure.
And here he is saying, well, we should put
Fauci in front of a firing squad.
Speaker 2: We're fighting communist Democrats.
Speaker 1: No, you're not.
There's no communists in the House and Senate
establishment rhinos.
Speaker 2: We're fighting against a system
that stole the election in 2020 and nobody's
been held accountable.
We're in a war with bureaucrats that have
forced vaccine mandates on us, mask mandates
on us.
And you know what?
They're pushing this wokeness confusion down
our throats now.
And by the way, we should try Anthony Fauci
and put him in front of a firing squad.
Speaker 1: A firing squad.
Whoa.
And the crowd loves it.
They love it.
Speaker 2: In for the Secret Service.
If they're listening.
I'm not advocating we kill Anthony Fauci until
he's convicted of his crimes through a court.
Speaker 1: Right.
A nice little clarification there.
Now, of course, this guy is very pro-life
and he respects life and he's Christian and
all of these different things.
Now, threatening government officials in the
United States is illegal under federal law.
My guess is the law doesn't apply to John
Bennett.
Right.
That that wouldn't really make any sense.
So kill Anthony Fauci, put him in front of
a firing squad.
This is unfortunately not something we can
just laugh off and write off.
There are really, truly dangerous people who
want to see Fauci dead.
You know how we know it isn't a joke.
Fauci has full time armed security.
He did anyway for the years during the height
of the pandemic.
I don't know if they've been able to ease
up on it now or not.
My guess is if stuff like this is going on,
he probably still needs the full time armed
security.
Now, lots of people would say something like
this about a public figure in a social media
status update and you would get a visit from
law enforcement if you said it about the president
or vice president or maybe even the speaker
of the House or a prominent senator.
You might even get a visit from Secret Service.
And yet here it's become normal to call for
executions in public forums.
And then you say to Secret Service, I'm not
really, you know, we'll kill them after we
try them or whatever, even if like what the
why would they even get the death penalty
for whatever you think they did, which they
didn't?
This is proof that you have this critical
mass of lack of intelligence glorified by
a base of people who are extraordinarily radical
and the fear mongering that's used against
them.
Remember, this is the reactionary toolbox
can be used to actually trigger them to go
out and take real world actions and remember
that, you know, we we were told time and time
again that this movement that is being built,
the MAGA movement and so on and so forth,
this is a special movement.
This is a unique movement.
It was unique.
And that these were a lot of people who because
they had never followed or been involved in
politics before, they had no idea of what
was over the line when it came to political
discourse.
And as a result, Trump combined with these
folks who had I don't know, they just like,
I guess Trump's the guy.
I never really paid attention to politics.
What Trump does must be normal.
It immediately normalized, for lack of a better
term, this type of political discourse locking
up people that haven't even been charged with
a crime, talking about eliminating people,
firing squads, etc..
Now, how many of them are actually willing
to do violence?
I don't think it's that many.
But the thing is, think through some numbers.
73, 74 million people voted for Donald Trump.
If it's only 2% of those voters that are willing
to do violence.
Right.
That's still a million and a half people.
That's that's a lot of people who are potentially
willing to do violence.
A lot of the people willing to do violence
also don't vote at all.
So it's probably actually an even higher number.
Unfortunately, when you look at numbers, like
one in four Republican voters believe some
aspect of Cunanan.
It's probably more than 2% of those Republican
voters that are theoretically willing to use
violence.
And you know what?
We know it's more how do we know?
A recent poll found that about 30% of Republicans
believed it would be acceptable to use violence.
Now, that doesn't mean they'd be the ones
doing it, but if 30% of Republicans say violence
would be acceptable.
At least a portion of them would be willing
to go out and do it.
So unfortunately, the numbers aren't good.
And we're going to go on now to something
else where it's really not looking good.